gentlemen we're live well we're
officially live episode number what what
is today because the number one 16. okay
116 with seth dylan the ceo of babylon b
fake news you can trust good to have you
back weather thanks for having me yes
uh last time we had john was more of an
interview uh format today will be more
podcasts
uh gerard is a big fan of your website i
know adam as well and so we're excited
to have you back you had elon musk on
recently yes how was that for you guys
insane uh i i was up until the last
minute right before it happened i had no
idea if it was actually going to happen
you know we were kind of going back and
forth with him dming talking about
having him on the podcast and he's like
come to austin and we'll do it so we're
coming with elon as we were dming with
him yeah on twitter he followed he
follows like 107 people on twitter we're
one of them um and so we're able to
access his dms and just and one of our
one of our employees just shot him a
message out of the dark you know i was
just like hey what's up bro you want to
come on our podcast
and we were not prepared i was on
vacation with my family and he responded
was like yeah come to austin so i left
from where we were instead of going home
and went straight out there with the
clothes on my back uh and rented a
studio to try to make it happen and so
we didn't even know if it was gonna
happen until the minute he walked in i
like the way you said that i said he
follows like 107 people like he didn't
know the exact exact number yeah
currently
it makes sense for him to be a fan of
babylon yeah it makes sense his
personality just makes sense to say you
know what i like what these guys are
doing so what was your favorite part of
the conversation with him
oh we went everywhere i mean we were
talking religion and theology we were
talking uh uh the current like cultural
climate wokeness uh he called it a mind
virus um you know we were getting into
that a little bit what's up
yeah so he was uh he was all over the
place but we were just letting him talk
you know we he talked a lot about some
of the stuff that he's um
um digging into right now with his
neural ink and
and the satellites he's launching into
space for starlink and all this stuff so
i mean it was a wide-ranging discussion
but um it was it was fun to just kind of
have like a
uh less serious interview with him you
know where we could make jokes and see
how he responded to those and he doesn't
always laugh at your jokes which can be
a little unsettling and unnerving when
you're there cracking jokes and he's
just kind of nodding along like you just
said something serious that's a little
it makes it it makes maybe your jokes
got to be funny or something yeah they
got i guess they gotta be funnier he
does like our jokes
but yeah it was a good time it was a
good time can you go on babylon b's
website right now let's just go right on
babylon b's website because you know
folks again if you
haven't followed these guys they're
hilarious for the work they do
uh put go go down to the story with
kamala harris and hillary clinton like
this the kind of stuff you guys write
which is uh go a little lower a little
lower right there click on that one
right there so kamala here is so
disliked nation considering hillary
clinton that's just hilarious to me
right let's let's see what else you guys
got that's recent
uh of seth which one would you say to
pull up let's see this one historian
discovers document from 1776
that removes all mandates and
restrictions
if you go to the trending tab that'll
show the ones that are being shared the
most recently okay the second one right
there right below the logo if you go up
go go above go all the way to the top
and click on trending
yeah right there there you go let's see
what we got
fbi said they still haven't found a
motive for 911.
to save tom biden to ship 500 million
free masks directly to
landfill fantastic historians discovered
okay we read that omicron vaccine to be
made available in march for the 12
people who haven't gotten omicron yet
politicians uh politician baffle baffles
nation by doing exactly what he said
he was going to do is the filibuster
racist a handy flow chart anyways just
and by the way this is a if you go to
put babylon beast best stories ever i
know we did this on the other channel
but we haven't done it here just go on
google and type in babylon bees
best stories ever okay best stories ever
yeah click on that there's a
what's the one side that's got the best
ones on there no not here they go back
uh
set do you know which one it is there's
a site that's got your best ever that
went viral here are the headlines
babylon people have okay go a little
lower there you go
okay right there ten best no it's not
that one anyways you guys had the the
one uh with uh trump that said that
trump says he's done more for
christianity than jesus himself oh yeah
uh that's uh right there i have done
more for christianity than jesus himself
and then the story comes out
that kind of similar thing to what he
said so the whole thing about satire you
said to me last time is
writing stories that seem so crazy that
eventually could come true yeah which is
happening to some of your stories you
guys are writing it happened to that one
yeah actually trump went on some
radio show where he said that he's uh
he's done more for religion in general
uh and christianity in particular than
any figure in history uh which is
basically what we said that he said in
that and but we said it a couple of
years ago and he just said it a couple
of months ago with how insane the world
is right now are you guys having a
tougher time than usual coming up with
topics because i feel like it's like how
do you get
you know more sarcastic and more insane
than what's happening right now how does
it work i i say tougher i mean well we
sit there and try to brainstorm every
day we look at the headlines and what's
going on in the news right and we start
pitching ideas back and forth um we
start with the headline just the the
joke is in the headline right and
we pitch these headlines and we have to
check like did this already happen did
someone already say this like and and
you have to think to yourself you know
like how long is this going to be satire
4 because uh this is probably coming
down the road here as soon as next week
or maybe even tomorrow uh and we find
that happening all the time so it's
funny we we we tweet about it all that
we have our our editor in chief kyle
mann and our managing editor joel berry
they'll tweet that you know another
babylon beef prophecy fulfilled and we
document those and and and share with
people when we see them come true is
that how not the bee came about is that
the idea there or
it it is i mean well what we were
discovering is you know the world is so
crazy the world's so absurd it's almost
impossible to be satirized so we might
as well have like this humor-based
entertainment site that just covers all
these crazy stories because they're very
entertaining the real stories really are
wild and entertaining you can just click
on any major news site and find a story
that's like wow is this headline real
so um we did create the site
specifically to cover those things the
things that are so crazy that should be
satire but somehow aren't so there's a
little bit of overlap between the sites
you know they start out satire on the
babylon b and then they become reality
on not to be speaking of overlap have
you found that the onion has been
subject to the same uh ridicule that you
guys have on social media or we're
subject to ridicule
oh you you tell me i mean i went to pull
up the babylon bee and it asked me if i
was going to a dangerous site so oh did
it really yeah we get a little bit of
that um you know
they have been um they've been targeted
with some criticism they do get fact
checked some the way that we've been
fact-checked i think look it's it's you
see the same kind of bias at play here
with comedy that you see in every area
of life it's you know the the mainstream
media is really friendly to
uh sources that agree with them and i
think you know the onion
is
this is one of the topics we discussed
in our interview with elon musk he was
talking about the onion and how it's
it's further left than we are right it's
very politically correct very
politically correct you know they hit
all they had all the jokes from the
angle that you would expect them to hit
them from more so today than it wasn't
that way when it first started they were
a lot of speaking truth to power i mean
the whole concept of comedy for people
that don't know i mean if you're finding
yourself agreeing with the establishment
as a comedian you're a bad comedian
you know the the idea of speaking truth
to power people don't know who lenny
bruce is lenny bruce spent half of his
career in jail for refusing to to for
just cursing at that point yeah for lewd
and vicidious behavior talking in the
50s yeah that was their culture at that
point but dude when i before i left new
york man i like you know i saw the tides
turning and i was like man this is not
about being funny this is about being on
message and then you saw people that
were getting you know fast-tracked
they're not gonna name names you can
really easily google them remember who
they are their careers were getting fat
they were doing mics at the village
lander the next thing you know they had
netflix specials because they were on
message and was like this is they're
skipping 10 years here well now you got
people like chappelle who are
doing netflix specials and taking a lot
of heat for it because they step outside
the bounds of where there's what they're
supposed to be joking about right and i
think that's what comedians should be
doing i think they should be
making those jokes that nobody wants you
to make yeah um
no no but he's not but the highest form
of the art he's right though the highest
form of the art is saying things people
don't want to hear in a way they can't
stop listening well
you might have text that what what steve
harvey had to say was that you was that
you yeah yeah he basically saying
chappell's the only person that can do
this any person out there other than
mice
speaking of himself he was talking about
dl hughley he's like
i will do one more special and that's
when i'm done because they're all
reliant on something
what's this point with that steve
because i'm gonna i'm gonna let it fly
and then i'm gonna go away yeah he can't
do it right
despite all the success i've had despite
all the money despite all the power
despite all the fame i'm beholden to
sponsors exactly worship hell has a
subscription with netflix exactly so
netflix is probably going to go after
more companies look at tim dillon tim
dillon's the guy tim dillon is a guy
that no relation to seth no relation to
seth tim dillon you know rogan
in a certain way i mean marcelo opens
for him you make your you make yourself
uncancelable by insulating it but at the
end of the day it's the marketplace
you know if if 90 000 people are willing
to pay 4.99 a month for tim dillon and
all the sponsors can shove he can say
whatever he wants to say those people
are supporting him it's one of the ways
that we're independent is because we
have a subscription platform people can
subscribe to support us and so we don't
have to worry so much about um and this
is the reason we launched it in the
first place is because we were we were
getting fact checked on facebook like
crazy they're rating our jokes false
they're giving our jokes a truth rating
yeah and then telling us jokes jokes and
telling jokes as they're supposed to be
a little uh have you ever gone they
don't have a truth rating they're funny
or they're not they're not true or false
have you ever gone down the rabbit hole
with who's fact checking you
because i was i got demonetized on
facebook and i went down the rabbit hole
and was looking at who fact-checked me
and you end up looking at it it's like
some bot out in in in singapore that has
no
existence it's it's like this person and
it's just an opinion this person says
that you know what you're saying is
false i was like it's satire well we
found some of them so i'll give you an
example of one we did a story on how
ruth bader ginsburg had over the ninth
circuit court had overturned the death
of ruth bader ginsburg that was the
headline right
and it's kind of a silly absurd headline
obviously you can't how do you overturn
somebody's death what does that even
mean obviously did they resurrect her
from the dead obviously it's a joke usa
today fact checked it rated it false and
if you scroll to the bottom of that fact
check it says it was paid for in part by
grants from facebook
so facebook paid usa today to fact check
our joke and then send us a warning
saying that we made a joke that was
false
so it's kind of a circular thing where
they're funding let me ask you pat talks
about
in the business planning workshop that's
where it really came to mind it talked
about finding an enemy finding an enemy
and that sort of motivates you to you
know double down on what you what you
want to accomplish and you know pat has
some enemies that i'm sure he'll talk
about uh vocally do you have enemies
that you say all right i don't know if
it's the onion or if it's the
establishment if it's cancer culture
who's the babylon b enemy who do you go
against
the enemy is anybody who's against free
speech the enemy is anybody who's trying
to censor you the enemy is anybody who's
trying to pressure you to censor
yourself so that you're not free to say
what you think and why you think it um
so you know anybody any comedian that
censors himself in deference to the
power that's trying to get him to censor
himself
is a joke himself i think and so
comedians should be pushing back on that
and making jokes humorous
so who is doing it right today who's
who's i mean obviously you got the
chappelles you got the rogans who else
would you put in the camp that is
pushing the envelope and not holding
back and who have you seen has made
major adjustments and gone and become
woke or soft any names in the market you
know the amount that's oh man the amount
of shattered freud i had watching all of
new york city who for
10 years i i saw gradually descend into
this non-stop you know uh carrying water
for for the state you know they just
became the this woke hardcore leftist
activist sect
and then they got shut down and they
were like the government but i'm like oh
oh oh there's the government
overreaching guys can't go to work oh
that's like so give me names though like
who do you think like who's who's give
the names of who is pushing back today
i'll tell you um some look the guy jp
sears jp series has done an unbelievable
job you know you interviewed jp sears
uh ryan long is
a lot of jokes that are like hilarious
dude ryan long um bill maher comments a
lot on cancel culture and he's very
anti-cancer he's more of an old-school
liberal who believes in freedom right
believes you you know he agrees with the
left on almost every issue the only the
thing that he doesn't agree with the
left on is uh this kind of authoritarian
attempt to silence anybody who disagrees
with them right so
and that applies to a lot of comedians
and he's felt a lot of pressure he he
faces calls to be canceled all the time
for the stuff that he says and mostly
what he's saying is stop cancel culture
and they want to cancel him for saying
that he'll say i can't stand trump i
can't stand what these guys are doing
but
stop trying to cancel these guys what
they have to say because even back in
the days if you think about
those who were against censorship
were
representing the left now it's them who
want to censor it it's the most 100 by
the way that's one of the weirdest
dynamics about today's climate is
how much hypocrisy there is
on both sides you have hypocrisy today
you have freedom of speech you have you
know my body my choice only when it
matters you have all of these areas that
it goes to id i need to id i need to
give you a vaccine passport but now when
it comes down to voting you go down you
say wait a minute
this is this is your core belief system
but you're completely opposite from this
yeah so when you go there you know what
typically happens when your philosophies
start having having uh contradictions in
them your own side starts saying you
know what i just i'm not feeling you no
more i'm just not feeling you no more
you know this is when you
people think just because you have a
found one they're always going to be
there like you know just because you're
famous you're always going to be famous
just because you know rogers don't said
something one time he said
here's how fame works everybody starts
off uh the first thing everybody says is
who's roger stone
who the hell is roger stone roger
stone's the guy that can get you elected
oh oh okay
get me roger stone okay phase number two
get me roger stone he says phase number
three is get somebody like roger stone
he says phase number four is who is
roger stone
meaning you're eventually forgotten
about it right full circle yeah so the
point is the political parties is
they're like celebrities they're they
were famous for a year and a half ago
liberals were famous a year and a half
ago meaning you're loved you're like oh
my gosh they're right trump sucks
and now they're thinking that was going
to continue and it's not because fame
and you know that whole loyalty if you
try to bully the voter voters that you
have
you can't bully your voters you can't
bully your customers you can't bully the
people that were loyal to you at one
point you have to constantly keep those
people it's a very hard thing to do by
the way something both sides struggle
with continuously you can fool some of
the people some of the time but you
can't fool all the people all the time
man and i think that you know one of the
things that concerns me more than
anything else pat is that i agree with
you
the hypocrisy is rampant but there seems
to be like people who seem to be like
okay with it all of a sudden whose
people though i disagree you disagree
yeah i disagree i don't think it's
people like i don't think it's
okay uh uh i've seen and let me just
explain because i've seen the goalposts
move
with my own friends sure what they will
do to maintain some semblance of uh of
allegiance to their their demagogue you
know what i'm saying it's like well you
know
i mean look look at the thing that that
we're not allowed to talk about right
like first it was gonna stop you from
getting sick then it's like well it just
stops the severity of sickness and then
it's like ah well it's gonna stop
somebody else from getting sick and now
like the next thing is gonna be like
well it gives you two points towards
heaven if you die like i mean like
what's this so there's always gonna like
it at no point yeah do any of them go
like wait a minute this is you know what
you got a point man this is i should
have been asking some more questions you
know you know the other day one one of
our guys that works for us one of our
executives his daughter
uh uh oldest daughter goes to school
and she comes after school finishing
college four years and she can't stand
that that's dad's philosophies
he says we had dinner and i'm like why
is my daughter whom i raised
so against me
why does she hate me so much because you
sent it to me hate these philosophies i
have so much and and he sat there and
he's like man i don't know and as a
parent this is a fear because you don't
want to lose your kids you love these
guys this is an emotional thing parents
today fear am i one day going to lose my
kids my kids go to school you guys know
where they go to
and the best school in florida is right
across the street everybody knows what
the best school in florida is but that
best school in florida is not one that's
teaching conservative philosophy so my
mind i'm like at what age
do i consider allowing the kids because
it's under my control till 18 at what
age do you want to be comfortable to
send them there that anything can be
taught
it's not they're not praying they ain't
sitting there talking about god they
ain't sitting there talking about
certain values and principles go at it
right they can teach anything they want
to teach your kids well communism is an
option socialism is an option you can
marry whoever you want to be if that
person's a he she whatever all this
stuff is confusing to a young kid that's
going through it right but here's here's
what i'm convinced here's what i'm
convinced years ago i'm sitting with um
a guy that's uh
raised great kids dudley
big fan a big big mentor my life
ran the biggest church in l.a and we're
sitting down uh and i said listen give
me tips on parenting and uh you know he
was going through something with his son
at the time he said there's three phases
parents go through first your kids
idolize you
then they demonize you
then they humanize you it's a phase and
a phase when parents go through
demonizing it sucks
it absolutely
sucks because you're like am i ever
gonna get these guys because you did
something wrong as a parent just a
matter of time before you screw up it
doesn't matter you're going to screw up
as a parent right he says then
eventually he's humanizing okay so take
that philosophy and bring it to
capitalism okay
you're a kid who do you admire the
lifestyle of the rich and famous you're
like oh man one day did i love to have
that life how cool would it be if one
day mom i'm gonna buy you a house mom
i'm telling you i'm gonna buy you a
house dad i'm gonna buy you that ferrari
you want how many kids i've spoken like
that right
and then you go to school and the
teacher says rich people are bad all
they do is they treat their employees
like slaves and this is what they do for
their own and they sit home and they got
these big bellies and they make their
money and their their employees are
doing the work and they're golfing and
the kids are like
these are horrible people oh my gosh i
hate rich people mom
they're terrible
and then they come out of college hating
capitalists and rich people
and then they go to school and then they
go get a job and all of a sudden
somebody gets a promotion over them who
for whatever reason
was a better ass kisser
was closer was a better friend or
whatever but you're doing harder work
and that person gets the promotion over
you
and then you're 28 years old and now
you're making 78 000
and you have to pay 13 000 in taxes and
you're sitting there saying this [ __ ]
doesn't make sense
what the hell is this all about and
eventually you say
maybe these capitals are not that bad so
what i'm trying to tell you is
i think we're about to go through the
humanizing phase of people that are
creating jobs i think you're about to go
through the humanizing phase to sit
there and realize these principles kind
of make sense and eventually that 12
percent that runs america is going to
figure it out and say you know what
i'm kind of going to go to freedom not
going towards control i think that's
what's going to be taking place well i
got a theory on it i mean you know i've
thought about this a lot right so
think about there's two aspects of it
who who becomes a teacher who becomes a
writer becomes a professor pretty pretty
intelligent people but they don't make a
lot of money so they become very
resentful into the system because here i
am i went to school i went to school
after school and then i went to school
after school and i've got all these
degrees and i have all this education
but i'm making 60 grand a year meanwhile
the plumber you know who while i was
studying was was partying on friday
nights is making 200 grand a year and he
didn't go to college you know what i
mean this guy the truck driver is making
150 grand a year so they're resentful of
the system in that because they think
they should get paid for who they are
not for what they offer and that's a big
thing that that that people mess up you
don't get paid for what you like to do
unless you're literally the best in the
world at it adam you're very good at
basketball but you're not getting paid
for it because you're not one of
literally the best 300 in the world at
it right so you have to be able to offer
services you can pave the driveway of
one of those guys that makes you know
that kind of money playing basketball
and do a real good life for yourself
because that guy doesn't want to pay his
own driveway you have to be able to
offer value if you're not the best in
the world it's something you have to be
able to offer value to the best in the
world that's number one number two we go
to school and we learn all about the
victories of government
think about it we learn about how
governments save the world in this war
we learned about how government saved
well history is written by the winners
exactly
right so government's great with the
civil rights act government is great
let's not let's not talk about how
government implemented slavery let's
talk about how government stops slavery
like you get all the wins of government
so here we are they're preaching this
the the egalitarian system where you
know your merit based on your education
is is what you should get paid on not
not the work that you do or your
willingness to do work tell just how
educated you are how smart you are and
look at how great government is so these
kids come out saying government's great
why wouldn't you want to pay taxes this
is how we do things and then you grow up
into the real world and this is the
whole thing with my libertarian
philosophy this is almost every
libertarian that i know it's like dude
just show your work you want more taxes
nobody nobody wants to drive on decrepit
roads and bad bridges
show what you do with the money because
right now you took 3 trillion and gave
us 1200
and nothing changed everything got worse
there's empty shelves there's a i just
went to buy furniture at city at city
furniture nothing is there until the end
of march this is the united states of
america i got nothing to the end of
march you've got uh you know empty
shelves somehow there's valentine's day
candy but there's nothing else i have no
idea how that works
so we gave you guys three trillion
and where's that money and you want more
of it
see that's the thing that the the left
never answers for you always want more
if 3 trillion couldn't fix it then six
trill your boy robert reich more more
more can you just show your work with
what you're doing now
can you just at least once prove that
the money we gave you was worth
something yeah before you ask for more i
mean it's insane i think i think you can
only do that for so long i i don't think
you can that's that philosophy is
sustainable and well let's go into our
main story here let's go into our main
stories i want to hear what seth has to
say about this as well first story we
want to get into is a great resignation
okay the great resignation there's a
story that everybody is talking about a
guy tagged me in a pic in a post i just
send it to you uh have it ready to bring
it up in a minute here i text it to you
so this is a cnbc story this is the
biggest reason people quit and it's 10
times more important than pay
from the data cluster review from the
last few years including before the
pandemic in 172 culture metrics at
roughly 600 companies researchers found
toxic work culture to be the biggest
factor that led people to quit and 10
times more important than pay in
predicting turnover okay so toxic
culture is number one is what they're
saying this is cnbc story the most
common ways employees describe toxic
culture at their company where through a
failure to promote diversity equity
inclusion workers feeling disrespected
unethical behavior or low integrity
abusive managers and a cutthroat
environment where they felt colleagues
were actively undermining so they're
describing cnn okay so what's
significant is that toxic workplace
factors lead to a stronger reaction
quitting
more so than other bad work issues
people may grumble about their workplace
being bureaucratic or feeling sl uh
siloed but they still don't leave but
signs of toxic war culture are making
people walk away so uh tyler just out of
curiosity is that the only story you
have on the great resignation or is
there anything else on great resignation
that you have uh on there that's it but
we can
pull a few things out it's been the top
story on linkedin it's like there's a
million stories so this one guy sends me
this
and he says you never talk about this on
the podcast i said okay let's talk about
it so corporations right now laid off
staff in 2020 okay
uh received generous government bailouts
totally agree a lot of people took the
bailouts shouldn't have taken they did
not need it a lot of companies didn't
need that bailout uh we had a board
meeting in our board meeting i brought
this up before where they said you know
we can get roughly four and a half
million dollars i said we're not taking
the money because we don't need the
restaurants needed i'm not taking that
four half million good for you but guess
what you don't have to pay it back i
said i'm not taking a penny my board was
upset with me saying every single one of
the boards we sit on they take the money
you ain't taking the money i'm not
taking the money why would i take the
money how hypocritical are my
philosophies to take that money and put
into the bank account but you know what
you're going to pay for through taxes
that makes you think you better take it
because you're going to pay through tax
that's my philosophy i totally get it
you're going to pay through tax i'm like
you know what i'm good the restaurant
needs it those 50 million employees in
america that are directly or indirectly
affected by those restaurants that have
to shut down let's kind of help those
guys that i'm going to be okay using
myths of resignation and labor shortage
to understaff okay
i i have no idea what you mean by that
but okay
this is a liberal facebook fan page just
so you know so i'm showing what they put
shovel work on people that don't have a
better option okay that's absolutely
ludicrous let me explain to you why
people have more options today than ever
before i'm going to show you something
from an economist i heard last week in
vegas that is going to blow you away and
it's not going to be a good look for a
certain president and it's not who you
think it is when i go through it shovel
work on people you know what the
challenge is today the challenge today
is here's how it works okay
you hire somebody
you give them forty five thousand
dollars they've never made forty five
thousand dollars you hire somebody to
give fifty five thousand dollars
but they have a now new title so they go
on linton and they change the title to
such and such title the recruiting firm
calls them saying hey your xyz at this
company yes we'll offer you seventy
thousand dollars with this other company
and they'll give you five thousand
dollar bonus
the guy has one month of experience in
that job so guess what he says he comes
back to the boss that gave him the job
and he says hey uh i love this place but
let me just tell you what offer i just
got if you give me the 70 000 and a 5
000 bonus we can we can keep you here
that boss is staying there and saying
what the
what do you want me to do
i need this guy but you're not worth
this dollar amount so then he sits there
and he says
dude i can't afford to pay you man that
kind of money but maybe we can bump you
to 60. let me see what i can do i'm
sorry i got to take this job he takes
that job at 70 000 with the 5 000
signing bonus a month later the same
recruiter calls him
calls another company says this other
company wants to pay you eighty two
thousand dollars with a seven thousand
dollar bonus this guy is under qualified
he says hey man you know i'm you know
i'm so sorry bro but you know i love
this place but you know it's a dude we
can't be do you ain't worried
dollars a 8200
i gotta go take the shot he takes that
job do you know i know a guy that went
through the cycle four times by the same
recruiter getting until he got to six
figures because a company was willing to
pay for it so that fourth one right
there is a bunch of uh gibberish yeah
but you can't blame that guy for taking
the money this is free agent no no no no
no wait a minute no hear me out in nba i
get how many guys get overpaid
because they had a big breakout season
or they did well in the playoffs and
next thing you know they were a two
million dollar guy now they're getting a
you know 50 million dollar five-year
contract what are you going to say well
i'm not really
i'm not citizen you're going to take the
money i'm not sitting here and telling
you anything first of all that guy's not
a loyalty guy he's loyal to us to money
go get your money do whatever people are
that's that's not true but fine no
problem i i say that company their comp
structure needs a better adjustment
meaning
if you want to get people to stick
around with you maybe give them equity
maybe give them long-term incentives
that they can participate in maybe you
got to make certain adjustments there i
don't disagree there but all i'm telling
you is people are
you say most people are driven by money
okay so let me ask you a question i'm
not saying most people are here for
money but i'm saying most people but
wait can i say this thing yes you're
making 45 55 and all of a sudden
someone's giving you a hundred and
you're actually thinking they're gonna
maybe maybe not they're taking the
hundreds of years
but but do you realize what you're
setting as your reputation on your
resume let me explain to you so so
you're thinking about getting married
one day no yes okay are you the richest
guy in the world
no that's elon musk so that means every
girl should leave their husbands and go
with the llama so let's just say you get
married to your wife let's just say
you're married to your girl drop that
gorgeous girl you're going to marry hot
girl we know that but let's just marry
your girlfriend i appreciate it but you
ain't the richest guy in miami you're
definitely in the richest june miami
so now she meets another jew okay who's
worth 100 million and he says wink wink
you come with me i'll get you an s 500
and i'll get you this house if you leave
me so now hey you should take your money
and go to the next guy and then she gets
another guy is that the like the way
well the difference is you can only
marry one person at the time
but the point is that's your mormon that
is not a good look on your resume to
show you have four jobs like one people
i agree with you on that you can't just
go from job to job to job the job but
that's what
that to me is also a mindset that you
can be bought you're for sale it is not
a good values and principles on the
individual you create a market and say i
come and i make it work here then you
force that company to pay you exactly
what you're worth in the marketplace
because they have to there is no choice
when i give you a promotion to coo i
have to pay you what the market is for
to sell if i give you a promotion to a
any promoter i have to pay you what the
market tells me you go on salary.com and
salary.com says what
the position
for a director of digital media in fort
lauderdale is the low 78 000 high 150
medium 100 whatever it's going to tell
me how [ __ ] i get dude so what do we got
am i going to get this or not i have to
work it because you're in favor if you
deliver that guy who changes position
four times the company is eventually
going to realize this guy's clueless and
he's going to get fired four months
later so then he has to go back and
explain to somebody else why he got
fired he's got to make an excuse well
you know it was because of equity and
because it's a toxic toxic environment
and it was just a terrible place seth i
got to tell you pat i've been in places
where that guy is terrible and doesn't
get fired specifically because he got
hired and that's worse for the company
because that company doesn't have
leadership and they're desperate let me
do the last one and i'll open it up i
want to hear you guys thoughts use the
myth of inflation to raise prices folks
that's not myth the myth that's called
math do me a favor go to one of the
slides that this chief economist jd
go up five slides uh uh uh and by the
way keep going up keep going up keep
going up i think that's the one no not
that one go one more yeah that one right
there okay can you make that bigger so
everybody can seize it and david can you
put that on the screen so everyone can
see it are we going back to that last
slide by the way because the guy only
got the one top thing right or the
second thing and then the last three
were just absolute garbage yeah but but
but if the media keeps saying toxic
toxic toxic toxic toxic here's what's
going on the company's inflation they're
just bullshitting using inflation to
raise prices here's what's going on with
energy inflation make it a little bit
bigger so they can see that
can you make that even bigger go bigger
bigger bigger so people can see the
years on the bottom okay so that shows
what energy inflation happened this year
look at that spike the last time it's
been this high was jimmy carter era
that's not a joke energy inflation ah
it's only 70 yeah it's only seven
percent yeah okay no no it's not seven
percent it's not seven percent oh yeah i
see what you're saying yeah yeah i i i
miss the satire i buy groceries
let me catch up to you guys i'm a little
bit behind i'll catch up give me a
couple minutes automobile inflation look
at that highest in how many years like
even carter was 28
dude that's 35 percent dude what are you
talking about seven percent who's saying
that it's a myth though yeah nobody in
their right mind
is a myth right now jen sackey said
that these companies are using inflation
to raise prices and that's
greedy they're being greedy right she i
went to starbucks the other day i tell
jen bae place an order for me for
whatever this thing that you ordered for
me i don't even know what it's called
she knows what it's called so
a fog something [ __ ] i don't know what
it's called anyways it's sick
so i get this tea and she says babe i
called everywhere all the starbucks that
i go order when i come back from the gym
with e
she says uh they don't have the product
what are you talking about so i go over
there so i look at the girl at the
cashier i said hey can i get this one we
don't have that can i get this one we
don't have that
what do you have
so she says honestly i said just put
something in let me go talk to the girl
at the front i go to the front the guy's
a die hard podcast fan die hard like the
entire time he would let me go because
he followed the podcast he says uh pat
we don't have 80 of our products to sell
i said what do you say we don't have
syrup we don't have this i can't sell
you this thing i said just make me
whatever he says let me see what i can
do guy goes to the back to make me
something that's not on the what do you
call it on the menu and he comes back oh
yeah they're raising prices
there's shortage of products if only
there was like six stuff 100 years of of
evidence of central planning failing
yeah like if only anyways i mean the
point is the point is that this article
by cnbc the average person reads this
article what do they say
you know here's here's how it goes okay
you know the guy that flirts with the 18
year old girl who doesn't have game and
the guy is 29 years old experience and
he sees this 18 year old girl that's
dating a guy that they're together or
like 20 year old girl and he says let me
ask you a question
does your boyfriend all he care about is
working out doesn't he
yeah
he spends more time at the gym than you
let me guess he's that good-looking guy
that only watches his car and plays
video games and hangs out at his boys
and he doesn't give you the attention
you deserve
yeah
if you were my girl from morning till
night you'd be my focus i'd give all my
attention to you and i think you need to
be treated that way
i'm a little uncomfortable
i would give all my attention to
him point is you write something like
this someone's going to say my job
doesn't promote diversity doesn't
promote equity it doesn't promote it is
it it is it's resentment yeah it's all
resentment so uh you know
when when people
say that their workplace is toxic and
they're listing these reasons i'm
thinking to myself you know what they're
saying is oh my boss makes more than me
this is a toxic environment like you
know uh there's not enough there's not
equity equity is like
is like having the same outcome
you know if you're if you're expecting
in the workplace that someone who works
harder than you is should have the same
outcome as you otherwise it's toxic then
you don't understand the workplace you
don't understand a meritocracy
right i mean and it's all it all comes
down to envy and resentment it comes
down to
wanting what other people have what
other people are willing to work for
that you're not willing to work for uh
and otherwise and if you don't have it
then you feel abused i mean it's like
this childish immature
resentful attitude that people are
bringing into the workplace when i when
i heard toxic i was thinking something
very different i was thinking it would
be something where there's like it's
like this bros world where the guys are
like you know the patriarchy is in
charge and there's like sexual
harassment and all this like uber yeah i
wasn't thinking diversity like the wolf
of wall street exactly wolf of wall
street you know all that kind of stuff
but i wasn't thinking diversity and
equity and and and all of that
hard to tell who the two business owners
on the panel are yeah but the uh look
i've been in toxic workplace
environments and i think what pat said
before is really really interesting
because
it's the amount of options that you have
and you made a correlation between this
and relationships it's the same thing
like before tinder before bumble you had
incentive to work things out with your
girl and then maybe you get through that
you get through your early hurdles in
the relationship and it turns into a
long-term thing but now it's just like
screw this swipe right swipe right swipe
right find somebody new it's the same
thing you know i
i told you about the the encounter i had
with the overzealous sales manager you
know where i almost caught a felony
that's the toxic workplace environment
now at the time uber didn't exist lyft
didn't exist you know now they do you
know what i and and during the pandemic
i went from two national tours getting
canceled to having to do construction
and lyft and you know what it wasn't bad
man
you could make like you can make 40 50
grand a year if you do live full-time
you just sitting in your own car you're
listening to music you're you have
nobody to answer to now you have the
liability in a way you're an
entrepreneur in that way you're taking
it upon yourself so i i am all for
employees
bettering themselves bettering their
using their opportunities to leverage
themselves into a life that they deserve
and i think at the end of the day this
will be a good thing for businesses to
adjust
but it's just like anything else you got
to compete for labor in the marketplace
right you have to compete so that guy in
your the guy who was paying the dude 40
000 the person at the end of that line
who pays 100 000 is probably a [ __ ] but
the guy who's playing 40 000 needs to
adjust his business model as well right
if he wants that same like we think
about this like you buy this at costco
it's 50 cents so we have a valuation and
this bottle of water is only 50 cents
but you go to the airport and it's four
dollars now the person that's been
paying 50 cents for this their whole
life is like who's the [ __ ] that's
paying four dollars you see three people
go up and buy it you're worth what
somebody's gonna pay you that's what
you're worth right so i mean are you
actually worth that well that's for
people like you to ascertain like what
is what is my stress level on talent
right what is my stress level on on
employment and then the other side of it
becomes you push too hard like the
unions have done forever and it's like
okay well now you're forcing us to find
another way
to
do your job because you're too expensive
in income the machines or the outgo
outsourcing things like that so i mean i
just think we're in a very disruptive
time right now where
i don't
there's people that again you know i
don't want to go on all these long rants
but it's like nobody you talk to kids
under 25 years old not a single one of
them thinks about the the buying a house
and the white picket fence and like they
just think that they're going to live
paycheck to paycheck their whole life so
i'll if i'm not enjoying what i'm doing
i'll bail and i'll find something else
yeah and and by the way that's the
concern and fyi so in business listen
kmart started off in 1962 and a half
it's called the super savings center
with walmart and target they all got
started same year that was the super
savings center which is everybody came
out with this concept of massive
facility cheap card memberships all this
stuff right
kmart and walmart started competing
k-mart got money five years later kmart
has 250 stores nationwide k-mart is
kicking everyone's ass guess how many
stores walmart has five years later from
1960 to a half guess how many they have
five years later kmart's got 250.
what do you think walmart's got where'd
they have it at the same time no they
started off 0-0 on 1962 and a half five
years later kmart raises money they got
250 kmart stores how many think
walmart's got a dozen a dozen he's close
nine
nine nine stores five years later today
kmart's out of business walmart has got
two and a half million employees what's
the point here you don't take care of
your people dude you ain't you ain't
gonna make it in capitalism this this
business sucks this concept of
capitalism you're just gonna sleep at
night if you're gonna sit there spending
your money going to gambling drinking
bullshitting not treating your guys good
someone's gonna come and do it better
than you it's that simple right walmart
proved it kmart circuit city blockbuster
you can go on and on and on with the
stories there is nothing that's the
great equalizer than business when you
don't take care of your people so
businesses have that pressure forever
but let me put the opposite side
there's more people that are employees
than there's businesses you also are
creating a reputation you know how i'm
going to put an idea out there if
somebody really did this i think this
would blow up i'm going to put this id
out there
you ready okay we have glassdoor no
so if you want to go right like you can
go to glasgow and check my ratings as a
ceo it's going to say oh this guy's this
guy's and you'll hear some stuff about
me right you can go check any c on
glassdoor fantastic okay you can go on
all these other places how about we flip
it we create a glasser for employees
every every time you work at a company
you get graded and the employer scores
you when you leave the company on who
you were now there's a glass there for
the employee so millions of people in
america now have a score for how good of
an employee
no no i'm sorry but but wait a minute if
the big guys have the pressure and they
got that magnifying glass under why
shouldn't everybody else i agree with
you so yeah isn't that what a resume is
they check no it's not no it's not are
you kidding me like you know when people
i do interviews and they'll i'll say so
hey there's a year and a half gap here
what happened my mom was sick i i was i
you know i was taking care of my mom
there you know it's just a very
emotional tough time for us like wow i'm
so what are you asking that moment
do you sit there
and the mom is 48 years old dude your
mom's a fitness model you're saying yeah
yeah yeah but the point is this is the
stuff that you don't see so if we really
want to go there i'm totally cool with
it man let's just put your score online
let's see how good of an employee you
are and then maybe we realized this
guy's been fired nine times in five
years okay no we ain't hiring you or
change because the market's overpaying
you and you suck flat your former
employee starts suing you yeah yeah the
former employee starts suing you yeah
because you're giving them bad ratings i
i think i think if there is i think if
this was an open thing that we all did
and there's accountability on both sides
let's go at it it's very simple let's go
at it so i think that there's a lot of
people that would be super into that i
think so too and i think maybe it's a
business model we ought to consider who
knows maybe we'll do it everybody else
doesn't go through it i'm going to say
one thing about this yeah
where you could like rate your exes or
something like that and it was like
i'm sure there's not a lot of vindictive
or anything like that
only women could date men we could rape
like dudes and then like but the problem
with it was was like you didn't make
your own
uh
oh man what the what was the name of
this you didn't make your own profile
somebody made a profile for you and then
like if you were a player they sent it
around and next thing you know it's like
it was called like pickle or something
like that what the heck
what was the name of this thing man bad
dating guy yeah dude
hey are you on pickle no
yeah
well that's the same thing with ex
bosses all things end poorly or else
they wouldn't end up giving you an idea
if you hired me at 16 years old this was
my resume you ready there you go you
should have hired me x-rated lets you
review your ex from hygiene to mojo to
all the world to see huh
okay it's called x-rated is what it's
called i don't know where i got pictures
2011 yeah 10 years ago
it's a lot better name than pickle but
yeah let's let's stay on this story he
was talking about some things
can you go to the same powerpoint by jd
i want to give this guy proper shout out
his name is jason doron he's the chief
investment officer of nlg
uh the guy's an absolute g he one time
him and i had dinner together in dallas
uh brilliant guy chief economist there
so go to go five down go five down five
down keep going going until it's the
three one more down one more down okay
right here check this out
go go a little bit so people can see
what the title is at the top so okay
what else is driving labor shortage you
know this entire time we're with this
guy he doesn't talk about inflation he
spends most of the time on this slide
right here wage
inflation
wage inflation wage inflation two slides
up go quick two slides up
wage inflation will declining labor
force participation can lead to
wage flation this is a complete
different angle on what's going on with
salary so go to two slides down watch
this here says number one
rising asset prices have allowed many
u.s citizens to retire early so he says
number one reason why this is taking
place is because boomers are leaving the
workforce their million half is now 3-2
so they can retire now because we're
paying them rent exactly so now they're
going to say look i'm out here but
remember baby boomers are 76 million of
them so if these guys retire it's not
all it's a lot of people that are
retiring that can still do the job the
second thing he talked about
is the younger generation is coming into
the workforce later so u.s citizens are
entering the workforce later than ever
more than 60 percent of americans have
completed at least one year of college
up from 40 in 1991 so they're going in
typically let's just say we're going to
work force at 22 now they're going in
26.
four years later so you're not getting
these guys that's a lot of sense and
then the last one he talks about is
immigration into the united states at
multi-year lows since 2016
net migration into the united states has
fallen 76 percent can you zoom in on
that because i want people to see those
numbers that's not a small number zoom
in a little bit more and take it to the
left yeah a little bit more okay that's
perfect
so
that's the legal uh impact that's the
legal yeah right that's the legal i also
like how that counseling is net
migration so does that mean that there's
a lot of people making money that are
leaving the united states well that's
that could be the case as well but look
at that so look at from 2010 698
000 per year to 774 000 goes up goes up
goes up then 2016 trump gets elected
million 47 then it drops to 930 702 477
247 that's a low so that means we're
also not getting some of these engineers
that are coming from india or some of
these people that are coming from
different places that are helping so
the bigger concern he emphasized was
wage flation not inflation you as an
employer you feel that when you're going
out there trying to recruit people
you're like man i want to get this guy
here but [ __ ] the rate for this is this
and if i bring this guy from new york
your media company
he's making 110 over there how do i sell
them to come over here it becomes
unsustainable because you end up you
know you got when they're saying oh you
know i got all these offers other places
you know and then they're trying to
leverage those offers to stay where they
are but for higher pay it's you have to
make a determination is it worth it to
you to pay them that amount and if you
don't have any other options in some
cases you have to bite the bullet and do
it and the business suffers as a result
of it so david if you can get off that
and just come back to us so we can talk
about this it does it definitely does so
this
is what forces many business owners that
sit there and say
maybe i gotta outsource maybe i got to
get more technology maybe i got to
figure out a way to automate this maybe
i got some of the stuff you got to
figure out a way to automate because
this is going to impact you know what's
going to impact the most it's going to
impact the guy that's running a business
making you know grossing 3 million and
they're netting 200 000
he's gonna take a hit because he can't
afford to do that right it's gonna
impact the guy that runs a you know a
restaurant with 50 employees and also is
going to sit there and say dude
how am i going to because how many
boomers have you seen as waiters i go to
casa de angelo i swear to god there's
like seven uh bar uh seven uh what do
you call it waiters that are 55 plus
that's a boomer
they're they're nearly 60 years old and
they're waiting that's a pretty good six
figure income salary so if these guys
are like i want to get out of it dude
how do i replace this well that's the
same thing think about that like i mean
you know if if you're offering me
50 grand and i can make 50 grand as a
bartender on the beach
which one am i doing i can't see you as
a bartender 100 bro
you would crush it i think the floor has
come up i mean if you know just a little
bit of spotify and you know just how to
create just a lit like a a small
internet business for yourself something
on instagram with some targeted ads i
mean you can make 35 000 from home just
just doing automated ads something you
know what i mean so i mean there's
there again it's a disruptive thing the
business owners have to compete for the
labor the same way labor has to compete
for the job the business owners have to
compete for the labor and i i do i feel
bad for the business owner as a failed
business owner myself yeah you put
everything into it but also the fact
that guy has to you know eat 50 grand
and go from a 250 000 net to a 200 000
net boo hoo i want my extra ten thousand
like you know what i'm saying that's
that's the game that's the game that's
being played right now you guys want the
labor
the the the the labor wants the capital
and the person who's really killing it
is the people who who own the other is a
solution to just keep paying people more
or to find a way to get more people into
the workplace and stay in the workplace
i think the solution is well this well
we didn't even talk about like who has
access to credit and who doesn't i mean
you know that's another thing who has
access to lines of credit who can play
the long game but then but then that
goes against your argument oh let me
explain why let me explain how and why
so for example
um
okay who the who who what who reads this
and says hell yeah
who reads this and says hell yeah who
reads this and says i freaking
who else though international
conglomerates who else the employees
were getting paid more no no the main
you're right it's the employees getting
paid more but who sits there and says i
freaking love this i hope this goes
another 10 years guess who you're on the
right track
thanks
the big companies oh yeah
the big companies are sitting there
saying hell yeah
force
my competition to go out of business
sure now here's the part anyone who can
afford it exactly so here's the part
here's the part
who
do big businesses hate the most when
they wake up in the morning competition
small business government regulation i
don't know they love regular i don't
know if they hate those guys believe it
or not i think what's happened the last
two years
you really think bezos wakes up and says
oh that was a terrible
you know three trillion dollars we said
we should have never done that oh okay
you made an initial 80 billion dollars
or 200. you're that that benefited here
so who this guy who got shut down during
the pandemic who didn't yeah tell you i
think the big businesses are scared of
the little guys on down the block one
million percent tell me why the big
businesses are scared a little bit what
i'm talking about i mean the little guys
are patrick beverly the little guys are
these these players that are just
annoying you it's the small business
owner that's annoying you it's the
message he can give that you can no
longer give because they can nip away at
the market the little guy is this guy
the little guy is us the little guys the
guys like listen come work for us we
want to change the world we want to do
something big the big guy's like well
you know we're going to give you better
benefits oh [ __ ] little guy's like let's
go against those guys those guys are the
enemy let's go be let's go do it the
right way people are turned on by the
little guy the little guy is very very
annoying to the big guys so for you as
you're saying that i agree
i think
i think you know the whole what did you
call it the tree filtering fire what
there's a word you use i said every once
in a while the forest needs to go
through its self uh there's a word for
it you know where forests catch on fire
and then you have to you know kind of
get more sun yeah every once in a while
you kind of got to go through that where
some people get filtered out and don't
make it and some people got to get
filtered out both on the employee end
and as well
i totally get that but if your
philosophy continues
the guys that are the biggest pain in
the ass to biggest business owners are
your allies small business owners those
are the guys that can't afford this i
don't i don't disagree with you on a
theoretical level but on a baseline
level i don't think the person who's
trying to feed their family has to worry
about
you know in 10 years out what is this
what does this mean for the global
economy i think that if they have the
act the opportunity to
25 that you know percent their income
they have to take it in that moment
right so and this and again when i when
i talked about access to
you know financing access to if you have
receivables you have access to to money
that normal people don't and if your
business goes under you can bk without
personal responsibility in a way that
people can't personally bk right so
there's there's different protections
available for businesses as well that
aren't available for sole proprietors or
employees right so i mean there's
there's a level of risk in all of this
for everybody yeah the the difference is
in a business when it goes
um
you you you lose
everything that goes with that business
the reputation the investors the idea of
coming back and doing it again you know
we hear a lot of success stories but
what you don't hear about is a lot of
guys that people they don't want to
invest in because their first deal
second third deal didn't go on like
listen i'm done you know you can't
figure this thing out there's that story
as well i agree with you on what you're
saying on the on the personal side but
you know on the personal side there's a
lot less risk and it's a safer
environment to be what an employee oh my
gosh it's a lot it's a lot more
you you you listen
i've been an employee and i was a bad
employee okay uh
bob's big boy did the right thing firing
me okay you're far from bob's big i got
fights i'm very proud of it bob's big
boy fired me because i ate the coleslaw
in the walk-in freezer and too many
times they told me that was you that
coleslaw was delicious
bob's big boy and glendale burbank if
you remember those days i i loved your
coleslaw it was frozen it was frozen
burger king i was a terrible chef they
wouldn't make me cashier good thing they
fired me they didn't work out
haagen-dazs haagen-dazs i probably gave
away more free ice cream and i worked i
was just like a guy that was having fun
with everybody working there yeah that
guy should have gotten fired i go to the
military i get my ass gig i come back i
become a great employee i become a great
leader things change life changes etc
etc i totally get that part but on the
individual side
like listen today you're like dude you
don't want to take care of me i got
another job go
i got another place to go go the
employer can't lead you most employers
are afraid to leave now the employer
that's done a good job and save money
like you want to go go i'm going to find
the right guy don't worry
the small business owner who's only
sitting on hundred thousand dollars on
the bank he can't afford to lose you
and today employees are bullying small
business owners than the other way
around not big business owners you can't
bully the big business owner they don't
give a [ __ ] go
but the small business owner today
gerard is getting sure how much of that
too though is
the lifestyle changes like again the
younger generation they're living in
vans minimalist lifestyle one again when
i was growing up if you were 21 living
at home you were a loser if you were 25
and you had roommates you were a loser
like now everybody lives at home until
they're 30 or they've got six roommates
in brooklyn like
everybody has this minimalist lifestyle
this entire younger generation the
zenios or the millennials it's all about
limiting their liabilities so that they
can have freedom they're exchanging the
the wealth dream for a freedom dream
they want to be able to travel whenever
they want they want to be able to do
whatever they want so so again i don't
have a problem with that don't that's
great as employers i just all i'm saying
is that in this environment yeah i just
think whoever adapts to this new
generation of employees is going to win
i i i you so
their their their
motivations are different is what i'm
saying they're not getting married at 22
like our parents did they're not raising
them
that's just a bunch of gibberish and let
me tell you why it's not yes it is
absolutely it's a bunch of things
no it's a bunch of gibberish listen what
are you talking about like the woodstock
era hippie era what were they doing were
they like all maximalist no they were
minimalist a very small percentage of
the population and it's a very minimal
percentage you know how inspired people
are today to go create and everybody
today wants to be an entrepreneur how
many people's twitter profile in 1930
said i want to be an entrepreneur no but
again that doesn't doesn't that speak to
my point that there's no options out
there no it means today people are
inspired to make an impact they want to
do something but
they saw what happened in 0-8 that's the
whole story where it goes through this
happened after oh wait they saw their
parents lose their house over the
mortgage crisis that happened and said
listen
i don't necessarily think buying a house
is the american dream and i think that's
the part of it let me let me show one
tweet i want to get uh set's feedback
here go to go to uh our friend robert
reich the motivational speaker
who said
do you know how much ceo pay has
skyrocketed since 1987 a hundred percent
500 percent try
this is unsustainable huh i responded
it's a source of inspiration for kids to
be a ceo one day mba's 1978 mvp bill
walton made a hundred thousand dollars
now steph curry makes 46 million dollars
a year that's an increase of six
thousand percent is that unfair that
people playing a game make more money
than ceos creating a job i'm happy for
both you sound bitter towards ceos fyi
you know how much the highest paid
professor makes in america today
do you know the number highest paid
including book sales or no no no just
highest paid professor what do you think
he makes
he or she makes it a 100 grand man
way more
no more i'm actually curious what you
say they don't make a ton of money man
give me the highest paid professor how
much you make that actually researchers
yesterday
the high you gotta assume it's somebody
that's teaching law at uh university at
harvard or something like that
a million dollars a year four hundred
grand okay that's a lot of money for
professors for the highest paid
factory makes 400 grand plus
yeah
so highest paid professor in america
today i want to i want to pull this up
highest paid professor i don't know if i
send you robin d'angelo 50 000 no no no
no you're about to be shell-shocked the
highest paid professor in america today
pull it up it's the first one right
there go up there david silvers folks
he makes
ready
4.33 million a year what professor
clinical professor at dermatology and
pathology
4.3 million dollars zev
rose and wax makes 3.3 million dollars
professor these poor professors are
broke yeah are they getting paid by the
school that
these are private universities at least
okay william 1.9 million 1.19 million
anyways so so the point is the point is
should we not pay these professors i
don't care if they're making that kind
of money totally fine with that yeah
they never go after nba players for the
amount of money they're making hell
what's his name mahomes just got a half
a billion dollar contract and he bought
the royals as a 22 year old player yeah
so you know this whole thing with robert
wright going after business owners what
are your thoughts on this with his
position on ceos having their salaries
increased by 1300 percent well i mean i
think you nailed it bitterness right it
he sounds better towards them resentful
um you know
the the first of all i'd be interested
in knowing when he's talking about the
pay increasing you know a lot of this a
lot of this is ceos oftentimes have
equity right and their value their net
worth goes up yeah um a lot more than
their pay this is one of the topics we
were getting into with elon musk a
little bit he was like you know people
are mad people are acting like i don't
pay enough in taxes because on this
you know i have hundreds of billions of
dollars and i'm not paying enough taxes
he's like my value is in my tesla stock
you know investors decided that tesla's
a trillion dollar company and i own 20
of that company which means i'm worth
200 billion dollars and that doesn't
mean i haven't realized those gains so
i'm not going to pay taxes on that on
that money and the second he starts
selling it off it goes down so it's not
even real yeah and it may go down the
value of tesla may may go way down next
year and then his net worth goes way
down um but those things come and go but
he took the risk of building that
company almost went bankrupt at certain
points
but yeah i mean ceos take a lot of risk
you know if they're providing value that
results in that kind of pay then that's
good for them and people should be
inspired to try to get to those roles
those positions rather than saying you
know what you make more than me that's
wrong we should make the same amount um
that kind of like that's actually i
think the employees should make as much
of the ceo anybody like we work with
hundreds and hundreds of people i've
never heard anybody here in this
building or any other company i work for
that say what is the word you know what
i should make as much as pat you should
hang out with some more socialists
do you remember that company maybe in
like the corners of brooklyn but i don't
know anybody in the in the in the in the
real world that actually thinks that the
underwriter should make as much as the
ceo who was the guy that's never
happened
who was the guy that uh that was a ceo
and he was making like a couple million
or five million a year
i had him on i had him yeah yeah he
decided everybody
right including himself right they all
got paid the same like does that make
him how did that work out for him how
did that work out you know what i asked
him when i interviewed him what i said
let me ask a question you think
everybody should be paid the same i do
i said who owns your company he says i
do i said wow you're 100 percent 100 of
the company wow your company does a lot
so you're worth about 100 million
dollars i am i said how many employees
you got you said 100 i said i think you
should follow your philosophy and give
everybody one percent of equity right so
if you really share it or about and you
should have seen that if you've never
seen this interview you got to watch
that reaction he was so upset with me
when i asked that question i said it's
equity yeah you you if you really want
to follow that philosophy follow it all
the way through right he says i'm going
to think about it
salary dude equity matters so much more
than i agree equity is the fastest way
to wealth creation in a business that's
growing you hold equity in that business
that's how you create wealth not by
trying to incrementally increase your
salary over and over and over again so
you know ceos that get there that figure
that out you know they deserve that
money yeah with millions of sleepless
nights missing a lot of parties by the
way that's stant uh the whole uh 1322
i'm gonna look it up because yesterday
ruslan sent me a text saying i don't
know if you saw that he sent a message
saying is this calculated based on this
i said just go read this link here's how
they came up with that with that formula
the formula that everybody keeps talking
about ceos were paid 350 times more than
employees all this other stuff go all
the way down what what do you think was
the average ceo of a top 350 firms in
america in 1978.
gerard what do you think is the average
salary
into the top three 50 firms in today's
equivalency or no no in that time um in
the not inflation just pure what was
their salary 1970 1978 what was their
salary well i mean
you know what who yeah
78 reggie jackson was the first million
dollar player right is that true so
let's say 500 000. okay cool go down by
the way this is the average of time less
than that right you're right it's less
than that now watch this
i looked at this i'm like there's no way
keep going down keep going you'll see it
it's a very it's a uh chart right there
the average salary of a realized ceo
realized uh compensation was 1.7 million
in 1978 what exactly okay and today's 24
million dollars so they're upset but
they forget that in 1978 they were
making 1.7 million tyler what's up more
than that tyler what's 1.7 million in
1978 dollars today
what's the equivalency
well it's 1.7 million in 1978. these
conversations to me man are like they're
just so like distasteful but but here's
the part of gerard if it's not what
somebody else is making if it's not
unpacked it sounds like what up
are you hitting me of course these guys
shouldn't be paid this kind of money
this is what they do this is the minute
let's find out here go 1.78 million
is that a million or billion i think you
put a billion good ones there which is
fine yeah
seven point six okay yeah so it's what
three times more
three times more than the average
inflation rate of 3.36 okay yeah so and
they've created more value bigger
companies more employees they get paid
more so the idea you build you win i
mean winners winners are supposed to win
i mean that's the idea man like so then
the formulas really they should say it's
increased three times more yeah adjust
it to inflation but they'll never say
that this is how you lie with money so
just like the just like our great
emperor joe biden said the media needs
to do more to stop disinformation well
and this is this is what creates the
resentment that leads people to thinking
they're working in a toxic workplace
right like this is they don't have to
say they don't have to say everybody
should be paid the same they just have
to say they shouldn't be paid anywhere
near as much as they're being paid and
then they can get everybody else to
resent them that's right and then they
feel the pressure to have to readjust
how their company is structured to try
to make everybody happy but seth they
somehow make it like that money should
have been your money like that money
created was somehow supposed to be
somebody else's money everybody looks at
it like like it's a big slice of pizza
and if this guy has two slices that's
one less slice for you it's not it's air
in the balloon if anybody wants to do a
fun little thing draw a little square in
a balloon and blow air in it and as the
whole balloon gets bigger watch that
square get bigger too that square is
yours so when the economy grows your
square grows with it it's not somebody
else what a great visual
what a great visual sauce talks money
visual by the way
we'll take care of that okay so let me
say one thing about employment you're
the last person and we're changing that
let's just say one thing about this
because obviously we've covered a lot of
what ceos thinks we have two i assume
you're ceo of your company or founder or
ceo
a a phrase that gets used or doesn't get
used enough i think
is the great reset everyone's talking
the great resignation everyone's
resigning resigning no these people are
following else unless they're just
sitting home collecting unemployment
which i don't know how many people are
still continuing to do that if they are
you know loserville but i think a lot of
people really are just it's the great
reset basically what cova did
is a lot of people had to sit home for
whether it was 3 6 9 12 months and say
is this really what i want to be doing
with my life is this am i working in
hospitality do i actually want to do
this or do i want to pursue something
else so a lot of people have taken this
time to say
let me reassess really and you've
touched on this is this is this giving
me meaning and purpose in my life and a
lot of people have just changed careers
i think 50 of workers are thinking about
changing an actual career so i know
we're talking about a lot of ceo and ceo
pay and a great resignation but these
people need to fall somewhere else
there's always going to be losers out
there that have no purpose or drive or
willpower that want to do something with
their life and they're just going to
take the government checks and the
stimulus and take the unemployment and
just leech off the government as much as
they can but a lot of people are saying
you know what i was working in
hospitality
you know there's a difference you talk
about this all the time there's a
difference between having a job and
having a career so all this great
reshuffle if you know if if maybe that's
a different term is people saying you
know what
i'm not finding fulfillment and finding
joy
let me find something i can do long term
that should be your goal so what
percentage is that because the flip side
of that is the following which you have
to be very careful with so
this one guy post something the other
day freaking ridiculous thing he posted
the other day uh cindy cobo sent it to
me i wish i want to give this guy a
shout out it was such a freaking
emotional thing to read
uh cindy you send it to me let me see
hang on one second guys i promise you
this story is worth you reading i'm
gonna send this to you uh uh it's by
sean whalen i don't know if you follow
sean whelan or not yeah lion's not sheep
uh is that what it is i don't i actually
don't follow him that guy actually owes
me ten thousand dollars because we bet
that
because we bet the guy with the beard
and the tattoos yeah yeah we bet much
like how we bet who would win the
presidential election
you got the money here yeah i did it you
paid sean whalen's duck pull out what i
just sent you and put it up so this guy
posts a story and i think it has a lot
to do with what you're saying and people
have to be very careful because a lot of
people can listen to what you just said
and said yeah that's exactly what i'm
doing
but the reality is you just could when
[ __ ] got tough let me show this to you
on what he put as a father with his son
so incredible incredible story
uh so can you make that bigger sir
that's him and his son okay that picture
itself is so emotional when you just
look at that kid look at that kid right
there all right so i love being a dad
more than i'll ever be able to orate
this is my son after bloody war of a
wrestling match tonight real talk he's
been hating wrestling this year he's 15
and in his head about a lot of stuff
trying to figure out a lot of things and
he flat out didn't want to wrestle i
told him he didn't have to wrestle but
he had to get a full-time job instead by
a certain date and he didn't so as a man
of his ward he wrestled it's been a
mental battle for him i've been watching
him and working to be a supportive but
encouraging that to hold space for him
but to push him this morning he got
pinned and i could feel his frustration
i could see in his energy he was mad and
dejected so after his match we had a
chat i told him as i've told him many
times that it's in a deep water a man is
forged in it's in the pain that the
strength is found and it's only the
hottest fires that makes the strongest
weapons
i told him earlier today that inside of
him was a savage a literal raging lunar
lunatic and that's who needed to show up
in the next match i told him to imagine
that this match determined if his family
literally lived or died i had him close
his eyes and visualize winning to
visualize his savage inside of him right
before he got on the mat tonight i
grabbed his face and told him i love you
now go be violent he went three rounds
bloodied his opponent and came off the
mat with the victory and blood pouring
out of his mouth i was emotional i was
choked up because i saw the savage i saw
the man who overcame the frustration and
fear and the man who will walk into life
and not suck him succumb to mediocrity
and pain life isn't is not fair life
isn't easy life wants to kill you
and beat you down at every turn and
tonight i saw my son dig into the place
in your soul that most humans run from
and avoid i saw in his eyes the savage
gladiator who will find peace in the
storm and who won't run from fear or
pain i love my children i love them
deeply when they are woven in my heart
they are woven in my heart and i ask god
every day to give me strength and
insight to lead them tonight was a
special experience i will never forget i
pray he never forgets this this is
emotional so to me adam as much as i
want to sit there and agree with you i
hate to say this to you a lot of people
call me when they're going through that
mode and you know what they're simply
doing things are hard and they're
quitting things are if you quit because
things are hard and it's really you're
in the heat of the moment
you ain't making a career change you're
gonna go to another job or company and
shit's gonna get hard there as well and
then you're gonna quit again it's like
relationship marriage is hard
relationships the hardest thing you'll
ever do what are you going to do go find
somebody else it's going to get hard
again and hard again and hard again for
10 or 20 of people that make sense that
are going through that i totally get it
for the other 80 percent that are
selective hearing they're looking for i
saw a sign on a billboard that told me
change careers yeah we can look for many
reasons to get you know a lot of
different things that leave behind
people have to be very careful on
messaging again i may be wrong but i'm
telling you i saw something like this i
would much rather teach my kid to say
brother good for him as a dad to say you
you're going to get a job you're going
to quit wrestling you know you're going
to do one of those or keep doing
wrestling anyways maybe wrong it is what
it is i admire a man like this i just
wanted to give him props thank you for
inspiring me to share the story or else
i would have forgotten let me just say
my yeah i've been at the same job for 15
years yeah you know it's the financial
industry you know what happened in 2008
you think i had a you think it was good
but give that message bro no no what i'm
saying to you is inject that philosophy
and that's fine dude you're a
millionaire because you didn't quit last
15 years i agree yeah you're a freaking
stab how many freaking times could you
been distracted and done something i
agree however if i hated my job two
years in and i didn't want to stay there
i would have found something else
you wake up every morning saying i can't
wait to do another live session not even
a little bit okay then right exactly but
how come you haven't quit
because now the money's too good
but how many how many how many years
into it did you start making money
uh
a couple years in it took me a couple
years and then there was a dip after the
recession and then i had to build my way
back you were in an industry that had a
lot of you know and a lot of people let
me just sing to your praises here
everyone
in um
everyone was basically trying to get
into the mortgage industry in two
thousand times 2007 2008. and then
everyone in the mortgage industry tried
to get into the financial services
industry and to look at the tables of
turnout everyone is getting out of the
financial services industry trying to
get into the mortgages it's just
everyone wants to follow a hot topic hot
trend i get it but this goes back to my
initial point think yes things will get
tough you got to stick it out it's not
always fun it's always sexy but you need
to find a career and ultimately what i'm
saying is if you're not happy in your
job
and you just need to take that reset or
you know resignation whatever but find
your career
more power to you bro but yes like this
guy like the rest don't do it because
it's not going to be easy whatever i
think everybody knows
whatever career path you take it's going
to be [ __ ] tough how long have you
been doing the writing business
uh i've been at the helm of the bee
since 2018. okay but saying when did you
start your your writing career uh well
i've been an entrepreneur since 2012.
okay so yeah at any point did you feel
like quitting or just now this is not
for me
yeah i mean it's it's hard work you know
i don't i don't get to take days off you
know it's it it it bleeds into my
vacation time my family time you know
it's very difficult it's very it's
strenuous and there's also obviously you
know all the risk that comes along with
it you know not not every business
succeeds i've had my share of failures
investments that failed or startups that
failed
um so yeah it's hard you got it you got
to pick yourself back up and and
continue to just push forward and and
and believe in yourself that you can get
there if you continue to to to go
instead of quitting right um the minute
you resign yourself to just thinking i'm
going to take the easy road well you may
you may it may be easier sure but it's
certainly not going to be as lucrative
or as fulfilling in the end um because
you didn't go out there and accomplish
as much i mean all these things that you
know the the the challenges the the
or what in the perseverance through it
is what builds character it's the same
thing like you never have an opportunity
to have any courage unless you're in
danger right like th these kinds of
things that the positives come in
response to the negatives um and and
that and that's how you that's how you
sharpen a blade is with that friction
right look at his eyes by the way look
at his eyes honestly look at his eye you
know for me eyes tell a story you know
what those eyes tell you
you said you have an eight and a
six-year-old yeah yeah dude those eyes
are like
you think i want to be by the business
or my kids dog like what do you want me
to tell it's the pain of a person right
that that part needs to be given more i
want to change subject because we
haven't had any of our subjects this
20-minute story became an hour and
10-minute story and we worked we had a
meeting yesterday to get more structured
and we broke our own
is our top story this was fantastic
fantastic okay next one uh joker loses
shot at tennis history as australia the
port star i'm going to read two of the
stories about this guy and can you pull
up some of the tweets uh uh in regards
to uh joker so
nomak uh djokovic anti-vaccination
stance uh has cost him a potential
payday of 2.1 million dollars in a shot
of tennis history after the play lost
his battle to remain in australia and
was deported the
serbian
boarded a flight from melbourne uh
airport late sunday night after the
nation's federal court upheld the
decision to revoke his entry permit over
fears his presence would strengthen
anti-vaccination sentiment it wasn't up
to the court to decide on the merits of
the decision only whether it was uh
illogical or legally unreasonable
unreasonable the player could face a
three-year ban from entering australia
but the prohibition may be waived if
there's uh under compelling
circumstances okay
so this whole situation of him what
people don't realize is i think this
would have caught this would have made
him the greatest of all time by winning
can you see who has the most majors and
i think they're all tied up
right federer djokovic
yeah and and if he wins he would have
been number one he would he almost won
one like two or three months ago like he
went second place because the other guy
beat him right by the way that would be
on
his winning record against him
individually he has a winning record
against federer individually he has a
winning record against the doll
individually so if he also has the most
majors and the argument starts to go in
his favor that he's the goat and you're
a tennis player so you would know this
stuff you follow the subject yeah there
you go so 20 20 20
uh total
six wimbledon eight uh for federal okay
so that's that part now go to what some
people have to say about this and i want
to get our panel here to see what their
thoughts are so uh uh who's this law
girl who is this person do we know who
this person or is just the user
okay djokovic cannot visit us australia
for three years we are we are the only
country that thinks it's okay to lock
out the number one tennis player on the
brink of being the best in the world not
because he's a health risk but because
he might make the 90 of its citizens
already backed not get a booster so go
to the next to it let's read a few of
these guys um make it bigger okay
joker is great tennis player he's a
great tennis mia pharaoh it's a great
tennis play but he lied and worse he
knowingly exposed people to covet had it
with him and every other arrogant
entitled person they're all dangerous in
one way or another there you go next one
is pierce morgan breaking
covet rule cheat immigration from liar
and anti-vaxxer icon novak djokovic
loses final appeal against deportation
and will be thrown out of australia
without being able to compete in aussie
open look at that picture yeah melbourne
right above him
and go to the next one there uh
ben who's from ben
dominic
i feel like australia underestimates how
this novak djokovic incident has grown
to tar the entire nation as
fundamentally anti-freedom and a place
you should not visit for a long time to
come as a tennis player yourself what do
you think about this story
uh i look i i think at this point
djokovic is a champion not just of
tennis but of freedom i mean he's he is
he is pushing for uh personal individual
freedom to be able to make your own
decisions um the the man is healthy the
man is currently healthy and he's not
he's prohibited from playing from
staying in the country from playing the
tournament why what is the reason for
that there's rules everybody has to
follow the rules but are the rules
stupid or are they reasonable
um you know if somebody's healthy and if
he gets the vax he can still spread
kovid
and people can still get it
then why is he prohibited from playing
just because he doesn't have it as his
individual choice the man's currently
healthy if he passes a covid test and
he's covet free when he walks into the
stadium why can't he play
that's my question but um you know he
was willing to put i mean look if he
wins this tournament which he was
actually fairly likely to win it um he's
the best player in the world right now
and he's won the australian open how
many times nine times maybe i think it's
like it's just like he's more than any
other like how nadal has the french open
he's got he's the one he's most likely
to win he'd win three and a half million
dollars um you know the fact that he's
taken the stance could potentially cost
him his sponsorships lacoste is looking
into whether or not they're going to
continue to have a relationship get out
of here he makes 30 million a year on on
sponsorships so that's i mean that's his
primary income right is his sponsor so
he put a lot at risk here to be able to
stand by a conviction i respect that um
and i and i'm disappointed in other
players who are piling on to him saying
you know he's selfish any major player
andy murray uh nadal's had comments no
doll's been it's almost hard on him yeah
what didn't adulterate he basically said
the tournament's bigger than any one
person you know the focus needs to not
be on him but he also said he knew the
rules before he showed up he knew the
rules he should have followed the rules
you know we all had to follow the rules
he's he's not he's not special he's not
an exception i think 98. he said all of
that 100 players are vast in the uh
yeah association well they're making
life easier for themselves and and you
know it it you have you have a choice to
make you either you have to pay there's
a sacrifice now and that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to make it
extremely costly to not go along with
the program and the question is does the
program even make sense
adam what are your thoughts on this
story
well look
i think and i've actually asked multiple
friends of mine who played tennis and
actually played
against federer you know these types of
like
legitimate people
and there's a couple different angles
that go here on the actual australia
like he did lie and you know mishandle
this and it was you know i forgot to do
this and he did show up to a freaking
photo shoot while having kovid so
he could have handled it better i'll
give you a different perspective
if you asked everyone in the world
everyone around here who are the best
tenant player most people would say
federer
okay most people would even say nadal i
don't know if
i think
nadal and federer specifically have such
a grasp on who is the best tennis player
because they're more likeable and have a
bigger persona and just their
personality is more djokovic i feel like
he doesn't have as much of and your
tennis player
as much
you know likeability within the tennis
world like we actually had like he's
tied as the greatest ever tied but
nobody i don't think really understood
that so i feel like there's a part of
him
that even with covid wants to get out
there win become the great to come to go
to you know become the goat
but i don't know if he has the the
likability of you ever seen those
interviews have you ever seen him do
interviews
not like i can tell you a lot about
federer's personality and nadal you know
good-looking suave dude i don't know
much about joker let me tell you i've
watched this guy's interviews and to me
i i look forward to his interviews
i look forward to his interviews
because
like you can feel the level of intensity
and commitment to his craft
and when he loses or makes a mistake
like one time he hit the ball i don't
know he hit the
person on the side i don't know what it
was a situation and i apologize
he felt like crap in the interview
afterwards like he was like
and it wasn't a big deal but he was like
it could you and you could felt feel the
sincerity i don't know he got booted out
of that tournament yeah i know he did
yeah i remember that i i know he did and
he said i deserved it like he didn't
even come out and like you know dak
prescott yesterday's like yeah i was a
referee they threw you know whatever
they threw stuff at the referee this guy
took responsibility for his actions i
think the fact that he
listen if you got kovit
you're this big of a name you can't go
to a place not tell people you got did
he have coverage i mean he tested
positively i don't know what he was
unreliable he had no symptoms you know
he's got no symptoms at all he does have
kobe now we should have tested it again
to make sure yeah by the way here's the
flip side of it here's a flip side of it
how many flights you think you're on
and people who are on flights have
covered it could be the person sitting
next to you you don't think people get
on flights that have covey anyways
gerard your thoughts we'll go to the
next subject after your thoughts here
tell us
bro
the most famous moment of michael
jordan's career is when he had a highly
contagious virus and he had 103 freaking
fever and he went out and won game six
the flu game that's a great it's the flu
game yep this dude was highly contagious
and was praised
for going for fighting through it how
many people did the evil michael jordan
bring up a really good pose just
influenza it's a different time it's a
different time where the wrong people
have the microphone we've got to tell
these people to shut up
anybody that from from australia that's
allowing their government to do this
you you're this is on you i've never met
anybody from australia that was this
type of person everybody from australia
i met was a man's man loved freedom
hardcore same thing with canada every
canadian i ever met was an awesome
awesome work and freedom love in person
and you're letting these tyrants take
over your country
like this that's what i'm saying the
rules are stupid man the rules are
dude we're not allowed to say mass
formation psychosis we're not allowed to
say it right but maybe we can say
collective munch hounds and syndrome
everybody's a threat to everybody now
everybody's sick everybody's a threat to
your well-being this is complete and
total [ __ ] dude this is one of the
healthiest human beings on earth
literally quantifiably one of the most
healthy human beings on earth and you
won't let him into your country because
he's a threat to your physical
well-being what type of crazy [ __ ]
world are we living in now right this is
outrageous yeah the only thing i would
tell you is the only thing i would tell
you is if
you're in a time like this at this level
of sensitivity in a country that's the
most sensitive
you you you have to take slightly a
different approach you don't have to
play the tournament don't show up these
are the rules they created okay you
can't go and say for example like what
you're saying to me
we're probably more on the same page on
what you're saying but this is australia
this is their rules if that's what
they're doing if you knew i don't know
the story if he knew or not that's the
part about the story with him and aaron
rodgers are kind of similar by the way a
little bit of kudos to nfl for not doing
anything to the guy so that tells you as
much as roger godell and nfl gets a lot
of heat good for them he's going to win
the mvp well what i'm saying is well
some of them are counting i don't know
if you've been following stories lately
they're saying brady may win it i think
it's rogers as mvp but they may give it
to brady but if you think about how
godel this kind of validates maybe the
nfl is doing a little bit better job
than we thought they're doing than
tennis especially for australia anyway
the next thing up is the french open and
it's going to be the same thing again
you didn't see the story that they said
they may not let them play in the
franchise they may not right yeah
exactly wimbledon is going to be
same-sex it's crazy to me you're saying
that's the next place
yeah well there's a lot of french
there's gonna be things because that's
not until may right so keep in mind i
think there's a there's an event in
dubai in the next few months there's a
miami open in march it's the people's
zone we'll see what happens with that
it's on the people it's on the people of
australia it's on the people of france
it's on the people to say enough's
enough this is nonsense just just a
quick comment too about your your his
reputation you know like i i mean i
follow the sport pretty closely i i know
a lot of people who don't like him and
who have kind of gotten that same
feeling like he's not a very likable guy
um whether that plays into this or not
and people are just out to get him i'm
cool with it i'm just saying not as
likeable as federer yeah maybe not um
you know federer for a long time got
real cocky remember federer started
walking out with a vest that had like
his initials on it like and he was the
greatest he's number one on his shoes
you know like he got here
he was but there was a lot of arrogance
there djokovic has never done that he's
never called himself you know the
greatest and worn number one on his
shoes and all that i've seen him
overturn calls that the umpire made in
his opponent's favor because he saw it
was clearly in when the umpire called it
well he was up 6-1 in that match guys
this is bigger than novak djokovic this
is they made an example out of him to
show the rest of the country who's in
charge and show the rest of the world
they won't want to lose they're in
charge they one way this is the thing
and this is this is i was just out of
miami and i did my whole thing on my
story and it was like here's the truth
of the matter man like we all have to
make a decision even if you're on that
team quote unquote if i want to go to a
restaurant in new york city do i really
have to show a permission slip from the
democratic party that i'm that i'm i'm
obedient enough to eat because let's
just say let that that's what it is
that's what the vax pass is it's a
permission slip to the elites that i'm
on board i i think may i
please have a slice of pizza please
i'm okay with the democrats like
how can you be okay with this but but
again again here's what it goes back to
jeddah diabeela was sitting right here
when she said
let them sink
i don't have a lot of money but the
little money that i have i'm going to
pick it up and leave people like that
are making a decision and
gerard
you know when you pick up a bad habit
how long does it take until you realize
it says this bad habit is running your
life uh 10 years or so
but watch what you just said i'm
actually being very serious with you
think about it we all have had a bad
habit got a hold of us i had a bad habit
that got ahold of us how hold of me how
long does it take until you realize it's
going to hurt you well how long do you
do you realize that it's going to hurt
you but then after
the longer it goes the longer it takes
to fix it man but but again but how long
until you realize there's a there's a
consequence to this battle there's a
difference between realizing it and
actually doing something about it though
i realize it and the guys
but just one other thing here what if
the other players what if nadal instead
of saying these are the rules you got to
follow what if nadal has said you know
what i'm not playing the australian nope
if they don't let djokovic play and then
and then if it like dominoes other guys
no tournament
great freaking point then they would
have to say you know what let the guy
play he's healthy
but do you know who did that in the nba
kevin durant yeah kyrie irving did he
stand with him he did he says i'm never
gonna ask him to do it yeah i support my
teammate yeah kevin durant and guess
what the nba finally said all right let
him play on the road yeah but the
difference is he actually played and
he's been dominating he's been mvp type
caliber durant now he's out for a month
though
but but to seth's point if durant said
look
i i'm gonna stand with kyrie and if he
can't play i can't play now if literally
the league's potential mvp is saying i'm
also not going to play and half the
players stand with them have weight they
have power people this goes but they're
they're they're basketball too much
they're not going to try to get into
their if they're not getting paid it
applies everywhere if we all stand up to
tyranny together then they can't push us
around anymore it's when everybody's
compliant and everybody's feeling that
pressure because ever 99 of people are
going along with it you stand out when
djokovic stands up and stands against it
he stands out he's the one that they can
strike down let me ask you a question
he's by himself how many of you guys
listening be honest
hear me out this is the part that i love
capitalism and competition you have no
idea how much i trust competition okay
how many of you are thinking about in
2022 family vacation straight up you're
going to australia anybody nothing
i'm so inspired you know
that's what's a great point
australia even if you're wax no one's
outside bro like what am i gonna do in
australia the other day i got a i got a
text from a guy on a cruise ship he's on
a cruise ship there's a 150 people on a
cruise ship that fits four thousand
he's like here's me having breakfast
with four other people literally
recorded the whole thing nobody what are
you going on a cruise ship for to be a
loner go to freaking different places
there's there's a price to be paid
here's your next babylon bee headline
not enough there's not enough tourists
to leave five stars
all right let's go let's go to the next
story here uh next story uh out of the
270 doctors in regards to joe rogan
trying to censor him only 100 were
actually doctors which is quite
interesting so let me
what page is that on by the way is that
a page five deal let me go to page five
uh following the release of a viral joe
rogan experience podcast episode
featuring guest dr robert malone a
letter from uh more than 270 doctors
describing rogan as a
by the way this is a post-millennial
story describer organ as a menace to
public health was sent to spotify during
urgent company sensor the podcast star
it's uh since been revealed though that
a large portion of those doctors are not
participating medical doctors over 50
were phd academics 60 were college
professors 29 were nurses 10 were
students former medical residents and a
handful of science podcasters were
included in the signatures
uh signatories of the letter dr malone's
interview has reached many tens of
millions of listeners vulnerable to
predatory medical misinformation mass
information massive information events
of this scale have extraordinary
dangerous ramifications the letter
states what what difference does it make
if all of them were doctors what if all
of them were doctors like doctors can't
disagree with each other i mean you know
going to get 270 doctors that say this
and you can find 270 that say something
different and that's debate right that's
heresy there is but one science and it
is the word of science how dare you
blaspheme science who get which doctors
get to speak for science who who who
decides which doctors get to speak for
science anthony fauci he is the science
he is science right i am the science
praise science praise be to the sun i
agree with you i don't think even if it
was
270 doctors 2 7 100 doctors that spotify
would have changed their stance
whatsoever we talked about this last
podcast they've they're winning right
now yeah and if they even if they were
even a little bit you know concerned
with these 270 doctors the fact that
it's just actually laughable it's like
well it's actually a nurse and actually
at a an emt and a couple drunk guys are
actually a intern like i don't want a
guy who stayed at a holiday and
expressed exactly i think it's only
going to strengthen their stance i don't
think spotify is going to do anything if
there's anybody that's uncancible at
this point yeah we're looking at them
right here
look this is the same thing that
happened with chappelle you try to
suppress speech like this and you draw
more attention to it it's the strength
effect the streisand effect
i tweeted about this yes the barber you
know what that is the barber strategy
let's hear about it home by like suing
the photographer that took the pictures
and the lawsuit attracted attention to
the pictures and then millions of people
saw them so she drew attention to these
pictures that she didn't want anybody to
see that's the streisand effect it
happens every time they try to censor
people like this i tweeted about this
when i saw that happen i'm like now i
have to watch this interview now i have
to i want to see what they don't want me
to see
but by the way just swoop for thought
here one of the most important men in
the world today i want to keep
emphasizing how important this man is
and protect this man folks i'm telling
you right now there's a guy named daniel
eck he is the ceo of a company called
spotify if it wasn't for him joe rogan
would be off of spotify power to daniel
act the ceo again highly paid ceo folks
we should be like really he makes a lot
of money evil yeah
17 billion more than the average spotify
artist
oh my gosh listen danny like your stud
keep doing what you're doing you're
impacting the world in a positive way
for giving a voice what i don't like
though pat is the what robert malone
told you in that in that interview that
doesn't exist the
the name that shall not be named
they
they went and and the biden
administration said don't say this he
says something and instead of them
counteracting it there's a hit piece the
next day
in the atlantic
and then social media linkedin and
twitter use that hit piece
as an excuse
to take him down as fake news right so
there's very very clear
causality causation the whole now
whatever but there's there's a very
clear chain of events here and it's like
man they've got a whole hit squad
infrastructure on how to justify taking
you down there's there's a literal plan
in place a censorship plan in place
that's coming from the people that we
have in charge of protecting there's
also
devastating you've got uh rumble hosted
his interview after youtube took it down
right didn't they they actually took
that down i think
i think that's something yeah rumble is
hosting the rumble's like an alternative
to youtube that's like a free speech
alternative and they're like they're the
views on that are going crazy and people
are flocking to rumble um so there's a
market response to this too where people
are you know getting fed up with youtube
and everybody telling them what they can
and can't see like let us decide for
ourselves let us take in information
from both sides and decide for ourselves
like trust us to do that i got a call
with the rumble ceo this week they
reached out
listen
all i trust
i'm telling you folks no matter how much
go through
idolizing competitors to demonizing
competitors to humanizing competitors
trust competition it's good for you
i'm telling you competition is good for
all of us let's go to the next story
because we can go 15 more minutes
desantis says there's something going on
with desantis and trump right now that's
a little bit uh i don't know if you guys
are following the story closely or not
desantis says he regrets not speaking
out much louder against trump's
recommendation to stay home okay
the santis this is a cnn story
florida governor desantis said one of
his biggest recruits in office was not
speaking out much louder in march 2020
former uh when former president trump
advised the nation to stay home to slow
the fast spreading coronavirus the
census blame people like dr anthony
voucher for advising trump to consider
shutdown fauci the country's top
infectious disease expert was part of
the coronavir response team that led by
vice president mike pence and included
other health public experts
public health experts but the decision
was trump's to make and desantis
ultimately followed the white house lead
closing florida schools government
buildings gyms bars and restaurants
dining rooms and advising floridians to
stay home
uh the other day trump was being
interviewed uh who was it being
interviewed by was it hannah oh no he
was being interviewed i don't know who
was being interviewed by and he said you
know there are certain governors out
there that don't even have the backbone
to say they've taken a booster didn't
say name didn't say name but we know the
girl that always interviews trump what's
her name from fox business uh bart is it
uh maria bartoroma
she was interviewing desantis and she
said hey governor santas have you taken
a booster and he didn't necessarily say
yes
didn't say yes i've taken a booster
trump when he was asked by hannity he
said yes what do you think is going on
here between trump and desantis
i think i think desantis is trying to
put distance between himself and trump
you know show that there's a difference
between him and how he handles things
because i mean like what trump is still
the front runner right for the
nomination i mean he's in the republican
party 76 yeah yeah he's still a front
runner um desantis you know has received
a lot of praise from the right on his
handling of things criticism from the
left you know they called him death
stantis and all of that um but you know
the lockdowns were so heavily criticized
on the right and a lot of people saw it
early on a lot of people said hey if we
keep kids home there's going to be
problems if we if we if we stay inside
you know there's going to be there's
going to be drug problems there's going
to be depression there's going to be
suicides there's going to be that you
know people were really telling a
warning about what would happen and a
lot of people went along with that i
think it's good that he's saying that he
regrets not coming against his strong i
don't know that you know
hindsight's always 20 20 right like can
you really know that that would have
been the right thing to impose at that
time uh maybe not but i think he's
trying to distance himself i got a
question for you follow up on that on
that topic sure
the only reason
he would distance himself
is because
he may run in 20 20 23 2024 because
if he really doesn't want to run for
president in 2023 2024
he wouldn't push too hard against trump
because he's gonna need trump's votes in
2028. so if he goes this angle the way i
perceive it is i think there's a my
chances of desantis wanting to run
officially went up 20 30 percent simply
because of his comment he made here
because that's how i see it you have no
other motive to call out trump in this
in this setting here than wait if you
really only run in 2028 i think he's
running i don't know i think he's
running in 2024 no i listen
that what he just said right there he's
trying to tell you
voting for me is very different than
voting for trump yeah that's a campaign
message again i may be wrong i think
that message works in the general
election there listen
if trump wants the republican nominee
everyone should just stay home and not
even waste their freaking time
republicans are on board with trump if
you're a anti-trump rhino whatever dude
move over trump has that nomination now
do i think trump is gonna go get elected
in the general election
likely not but we'll see we'll see if if
he's still as polarizing when it comes
to 2024 i don't think biden is going to
run again in 2024. if if i'm desantis i
look at the nonsense and i say i know
you might disagree you think you should
you know strike while the iron is hot i
look at the nonsense and i say dude
i'll just see you guys in 2028 and just
be the man and just and and and
completely dominate at that point i
don't think he wants to be in trump's
shadow i think that is
not good for his
long-term legacy being trump's vp i
don't think that's his look gerard you
die the hero you live long enough to see
yourself become the villain he's hot
right now he's never going to be hotter
there's never going to be a weaker
opponent if he's ever going to run it's
now if he waits four years that's four
more years but what do you mean by the
weaker opponent
the democratic party is yeah but i'm not
even talking about he has not even like
you got to get through your primary
before you even think about democrats
right now and he's a lot do you think
here's the question for sure you're a
pretty smart guy
if desantis runs
and obviously trump i think is going to
run is there any chance desantis
you know unseats trump as the um
as the nominee you the republican party
i think you'd be shocked
how many people traditional
conservatives would back desantis over
trump i i think that the map do you
think desantis would beat trump in a
primary is that what you're saying i'm
not saying that whatsoever i'm saying i
think it would be a better fight than
you think it would be and i i i
personally believe mega has always been
less about donald trump and more about
somebody anybody willing to fight back
against the the the the globalist i
think it's just trump that's it no
answer
can desantis beat trump in a primary
yeah for sure
for sure
there's no way you can have that kind of
confidence for sure
yeah can desantis beat trump in a
primary let me ask you a question why
would you ask a question if you weren't
going to accept an answer that came from
the i just i let me ask you a question
do you think white is black no it's not
you're an idiot what kind of a question
is that i just i i i respect the fact
that you actually think that way but i
just you think actually somebody in in
today's climate you think anybody can
beat trump in a republican primary i
swear to god i think sometimes man you
wake up in the middle of the night and
you think donald trump's standing over
your bed or something like that it's not
a boogie man the guy has the guy has 85
90 approval rating in the republican
party if not if it's higher than that
what's desantis
desantis isn't doing well in florida i
don't think people know him on the
national level
how much overlap do you think
donald trump's audience is with ron
desantis's
how much overlapping meaning similar
beliefs similar values similar how much
over those policies very similar very
similar how much overlap do you think
there is in ron desantis audience to
donald trump's
who has broader appeal
nationally sure desantis i i said i
would vote for desantis i wouldn't vote
for a trump so like you said the twelve
percent you just answered yourself yeah
but i'm not in the republican primary
are you talking about representatives
thought that it was john kasich who made
it to the end of the last case yeah
dude no that's i mean well that's a
traditional you know romney republican
governor of ohio every establishment gop
all the establishment gop money all the
donors they're all going to go what do
you think what do you think about
whether he'll run yeah
whether
he can beat trump if he runs
uh i mean these the polls change all the
time uh it's hard to predict those
things i i as of night if it was held
today i don't think he can beat trump
um
you know we'll see what happens over the
course of time what else happens what
else i think the media has done a very
good job of painting desantis as
reckless and uh getting it you know when
you go outside of florida and people
when they hear about what's going on in
florida you know a lot of people think
that florida is like
being like like running to the ground by
the san francisco he's just killing
people you know the media is like is
doing a good job everybody's moving to
florida i think you're way off man i got
so many friends and family in new york
new jersey connecticut they think ron
desantis is running the promised land
down here yeah well i mean the numbers
are people flooding here there's
something part of that out but there's
something
dude i'm in nevada i'm in california i'm
in different places here's what
everybody says
dude how bad is florida right now i'm
like what do you mean how bad is floyd
depends on where they are so
just just
and by the way the way you judge to me
who is the real candidate is who the
opposing side trashes more okay so so
check this out here check this out this
kind of validates his point okay go to
page six go to page six
uh january sixth
panel
member floats 14th amendment as a way
to bar trump from holding office this is
a washington examiner story
neither of donald trump's impeachment
trials led to his conviction which would
have prevented him from returning to the
white house
representative jamie raskin said has
another idea on how to borrow the former
president ruskin suggested that the
constitutional provision preventing
those who engage in insurrectionism or
rebellion from holding office may
prevent trump from becoming the
president for a second non-consecutive
term having lost to president joe biden
2020 trump is eligible for another white
house term polls show him the clear
favor to win the 2024 republican
nomination if he runs if they're people
who did participate in insurrection or
rebellion they're constitutionally
barred from holding federal or state
office again we're asking a member of
the white house select committee reform
the investigation in general
there's also another part of you know
for example donald trump has already
been determined to have participated in
the insurrection rebellion by the
virtual image okay so you see where the
story goes
that's bad news for george washington
and john adams huh yeah the the the
place where i'm going with this is where
i'm going with this is
who is mainstream media trashing the
most today
that's who you got to look at as the
number one yeah so so so i think they're
still this is the one guy
i was watching don lemon and chris cuomo
the night uh biden one when it was
announced at biden one and you see don
lemon is like
look i don't care what you're just
you're with us because we want and this
is you know this is just very emotional
right now good don lemon right now did
you see don
how he trashed biden last night i did no
yeah i don't hate myself enough to watch
yeah i was pretty bad i mean well it's a
horrible week with the voting rights and
the and the mask mandates
uh come on man worst week of a
presidency
could possibly have it's been a terrible
week for that guy to the point where don
comes after you
and mainstream media comes after you so
charlemagne the god yeah this website
called babylon b fake news you can trust
claims
kamala harris is so bad hillary clinton
dangerous website yes i don't know if
you know that side or not so dangerous
point is who the hell is
gonna run on the other side we still
can't come up with a name on that side
i don't know michelle obama we discussed
that
we'll see anyways okay so that's the
part with trump's story let me go to
another hillary clinton's considering
losing again is there i mean is there no
shame with this january 6 stuff i mean
is there just no shame whatsoever
they're just they found their narrative
they're sticking to it and and this
almost goes to what you were saying
before pat like you could fool people
some of the time and not all the time
there's so many democrats that i know i
mean i grew up with nothing but
democrats and as soon as they compared
this to 911 everybody around us was like
uh
what coming in
what's up now what i'm saying to you
what loyalty loyalty is loyalty is
you know you have to know that there's
your parents you ever seen your parents
are like okay yeah i don't know mom yeah
no that doesn't make any sense yeah that
i don't i don't know if we're going that
far
no matter when a bad argument is
presented you're going to sit there and
you're going to say
listen i know i'm a democrat yeah i'm a
registered democrat my entire life i
voted democrat i disagree with you it's
let's say 9 11. this is a completely
different story they've lost their mind
when they go to a different angle
anyways let's go to one story here
cowboys they lost again
can you pull up that stat uh that we
have on the amount of victories
uh uh uh the amount of victories the
playoffs the cowboys have did you see
that the last 25 years so here's a
question for you before you pull it up i
want to see what he's going to say i'll
send you the
uh what do you call it i'll send you the
tweet to put up there how many
victories do you think the cowboys have
had playoff victories since since 25
years the last 25 years when barry does
that go far enough back to yeah smith
and yes yes it does after the 25 years
25 years how many playoff wins do you
think the cowboys have had in the last
25 years tyler i'm gonna text it matter
of fact just go to my twitter profile
how many playoff victories you think
they've had 25 years asking in the last
25 years how many is it a handful go the
other way so you said a handful right go
the other way go the other way is it
five you said five yeah okay go a little
lower a little lower lower the lower if
it's not that way maybe it's the
opposite way i don't know go the other
way up go up go up go up go up go up
check this out you're about to be blown
away boom click on that click on that
the cowboys have had three victories in
playoffs 25 years colin kaepernick's got
four
guys brad johnson mark sanchez mark
sanchez ran into his lineman's got four
trend deal for five jake if you asked a
hundred nfl fans who jake the lomas they
couldn't tell you played for oh the
panthers man carolina he went to the
super bowl five i understand but five
more than the cowboys the last 25 years
so now here's the question
what what steven a smith's having a time
of his life okay yeah uh these guys all
year long people thought this was gonna
be the year that got the money okay a
lot of people thought this was their
year that they could do something that
got us money that got some really good
games i think he broke cowboy's record
with 37 touchdowns inside games yeah 17
i'm sure that's a good point but but i
think he missed a game i don't know if
he missed the game or something like
that yeah so it's really 16 games very
true yeah so you got to give him the
credit that he did that
what the hell is going on with these
guys last 25 years
what is it any any speculation at least
romo can now say it well it wasn't me
you know you know
i'm going to give you one about the
problem
you're going to have a hard time
defeating this okay because
in the past 40 years yeah you've said
there's been uh you know three two
republican uh two democratic presidents
three republicans we've had uh reagan
we've had bush we've had clinton back
and forth back and forth back who's been
the one constant
um
and it's been fouchy has it not yeah in
the past 25 years who's been the one
constant it wasn't jimmy johnson i
wasn't very sweaty for the sake of
jason garrett jerry jones your 85 year
old old ass you're out of touch buddy
time to take a move time to stop running
the team turn it over to somebody else
he is the one
constant if the capital plus he makes
too much money make waste waste if the
cowboys actually want to we need to yes
yeah that's true if the cowboys actually
want to you know get over the hurdle
jerry jones got to go
i you know do you have any other uh dude
i just think it's like it's just one of
those like the legacy media it's like
the cap you know i saw one tweet that
was uh from bar store that was hilarious
this is a rough year for the cowboy
yankee laker fan this is a tough year
for him dude it's a uh you know there's
there's so many franchises that are just
famous for being famous like notre dame
is on every saturday they haven't won
anything you know the cowboys america's
team they haven't won in a generation
man it's like uh these are the these are
the they did dominate in the nineties
but you got it yes they were the [ __ ]
yeah and game of thrones was amazing for
six seasons you know so okay so let me
see so let me ask you this so let me ask
you this let me ask you this okay so i
had this conversation with uh what is a
pen pen tom pen
yeah
yeah what are you describing when he was
a cap specialist
i said and he was a president of lafc
the soccer team he was a president of
that he's a numbers guy he's a numbers
guy so i said who's the most important
building is that is that the david
beckham one uh yes okay yeah i said so
who is the i think so i may be wrong
that's the galaxy that's the one yeah
beckham's here in miami yeah beckham
played for l.a the voice of god you're
upset david he's awake but then you
bring me soccer david's gonna hear me
out you got a few different things here
okay to build a championship team you
got the owner you got a gm you got a
coach you got a superstar which one are
they missing
none that's the whole point ooh the
cowboys
keep thinking the cowboys i disagree you
got okay so so for example if the
cowboys get
bill belichick to go there would things
change
well bill belichick can't turn the
franchise around but to your cred to
your answer
you said owners okay there you go but
wait a minute but wait a minute so so if
patrick mahomes is traded for prescott
are things going to change dallas had
the number one offense in the league and
most turnovers in the league they were a
good team this year and they just [ __ ]
the bed per usual right it's it's jerry
jones you know what it is maybe they
just need to say att stadium have they
thought about saging the stadium they
just got bad juju
who's the gm of the cowboys himself
exactly himself
i thought steven jones it says it says
owner and general manager of operations
he needs to step aside i agree let's get
some young juices into where i'm going
bringing it also the same
fauci needs to step aside trump needs to
step aside biden should run again let's
get all these old ass baby boomers out
the door have a great life we still love
you let's get some millennials and gen
x's is that a campaign speech because
you're running 2023 2024 vote for adam
davidson let's go adam is what's going
to happen by the way this thursday this
thursday this thursday rashad evans will
be here on the podcast
we're going to have a lot of different
conversation about the ufc cannot wait
for that folks put it in your calendar
same time thursday rashad evans will be
entering the vault having said that seth
appreciate you for coming out this was a
vlad man appreciate you thank you
everybody bye bye bye bye
you